[Music]
this morning in our school matters
series we're focusing on a very heated
issue that's become a big old flash
point in the debate over how to respond
to this pandemic we're talking about
mask mandates for students now some
school board meetings have turned into
confrontations between opponents and
supporters of the move a recent cbs news
poll found this only six percent of
parents say that mass mandates should
not be allowed while 58 percent say they
should absolutely be required 36 believe
mass should be optional but the voices
of those opponents are often the loudest
new jersey governor recently announced a
mass mandate for all schools and
employees were told to get vaccinated or
face covet test
meg oliver went to 110 school board
meeting in wayne new jersey
[Music]
the science says that kids do not carry
this stuff they do not spread it even
before the school board meeting in wayne
new jersey began families against the
school mask mandates gathered outside to
loudly protest why are you guys here
tonight to get mass off of
us
this school is it worth it to wear a
mask if it means your school is going to
open
no
i'm protesting for my body my choice
because
i believe that if someone wants to wear
a mask then they can wear a mask because
like it's their body and they get to
choose but also if someone doesn't
really want to wear a mask then people
don't really have the right to force it
on them so if you had a choice to wear a
mask and go to school or stay at home
what would it be
i would
i would want to wear a mask and go to
school actually but
that's actually a really tough question
that's a tough question right because
that's where we go to school
then we're being forced to wear a mask
but if we're staying at home then we're
being forced to stay at home
[Music]
the majority of the nearly 100 people at
this school board meeting were there to
express their frustration with new
jersey's school mask mandate and demand
the district stand up to the governor
science is not
fact
science is meant to be challenged there
is no pandemic amongst children
the young lady just said that there is
no pandemic among the children
the lady is either in denial or she's
just lying
because every newspaper excuse me i have
the microphone
the lady is misinformed or she is lying
you should be embarrassed and ashamed
with the agenda that all of you are
letting happening in this town there is
a well-orchestrated
well-coordinated
uh and loud movement of people here
i think it's important that you hear
uh from parents as well who support
the governor's mask mandate for k-12
schools now i support anyone who wants
to wear a mask that is their choice to
do so but if i'm going to respect their
right they need to respect mine i will
be telling both my boys not to wear
masks thank you
do you feel you're accomplishing
something with these meetings
well they're not optional uh whether i
feel we're accomplishing um i think it's
our job i think we were elected to serve
the community and part of that is
listening
we wanted to hear more from parents who
spoke out so we met up with dana aliquin
at a local park she's the mother of two
young children one who is autistic she's
not vaccinated and her kids are too
young to receive the shot
you were very vocal at this board
meeting what was your goal
really just to speak for the kids
i
personally
do not want to send my child with a mask
that's
you know my and my husband's
opinion there are no studies
done or being done
about the longevity of mask wearing in
children is there a world where you
would consider putting a mask on your
child to go to school this fall
not this fall do you believe that masks
can help reduce the transmission of
covet
if they're worn properly they can the
kids aren't wearing them properly and
that's also my big concern but if they
do wear them properly would you consider
sending your kids to school with the
mask um this year no because i just
think that my daughter went through it
last year it took a mental toll i think
it's hard for these kids to learn how to
read learn how to
do a lot of their lessons when their
teachers mouths are covered by the mask
and their peers masks it's a little
dehumanizing
a lot of people will argue that you're
part of a community and being part of a
community
you want to protect others by masking
and vaccinating what's your response to
that um i agree with that but the only
thing
to counter is
these people that don't feel safe
you know they're still going out food
shopping they're still going out to
concerts they're gonna they're still
going to the mall they're still going to
the beach if they were that terrified i
feel that if they felt that threatened i
feel that
they would be staying home and i don't
think that everyone collectively needs
to be punished for that but now you're
gonna
during our interview a local parent who
supports mass mandates recognized dana
yeah being loud
those opposing the school mask mandate
and those who support it have competing
petitions circulating online those who
support masks currently have around 700
more signatures
i wrote the opposing
petition by the way that has more
signatures than yours
this was their least appealing yeah and
most people agree with us
there's a a lot going on here
that's fine it's despicable okay you're
entitled to your opinion and i'm
entitled to mine are you vaccinated no
why not
shame on you
shame on you
i think a lot of people are going to
paint a picture of you if you're getting
up at a board meeting speaking that your
anti-mask your anti-vaccine
your anti-all these things is that
accurate no we
are not anti-anything we are fighting
for our god-given right
to choose what is best for our children
[Music]
in the past month the number of kids
contracting covid went from close to 40
000 to 180 000 by the end of last week
experts say if masks are worn properly
along with vaccinations ventilation and
testing they can help reduce the
transmission of covid in the classroom
and i have to say you know i called top
uh three of the top doctors across the
country yesterday to talk about some of
the things that these parents said and
they agreed that if we're not putting
these masks on our children the right
way
they're not effective so if you're going
to hand an adult mask to a kid this fall
turn the sides make sure it fits yeah i
thought that was a good take away i mean
as a parent i understand you don't even
if another parent tells my kids not to
run around the pool i'm like hey i got
it i got it right you don't want that
kind of interference but you know the
experts are saying this for a reason
they've been saying it for a long time
now it's clear it's settled it's
interesting to see the exchange between
the two parents because did their kids
know each other no but they were playing
together before our interview started
and they didn't realize it before the
kids went away
oh boy meg thank you very much